[Música]
[Aplausos]
música para cenar con amigos música para
salir a caminar por la montaña
barilochense música para aumentar la
productividad música para salir a correr
música para la buena onda
[Música]
música para
caminar como peter parker en spider-man
[Música]
muchos de nosotros
utilizamos las plataformas
streaming de música desde cualquier
dispositivo con conexión accedemos a
miles de canciones con una calidad
interesante en una de ellas
existe una sección llamada playlist
donde hay
canciones agrupadas bajo un título como
recién nombraba algunas son verdaderas
la última es verdadera
a mí eso me hizo ruido siempre porque me
surgen dos preguntas que se las hago a
ustedes ahora se puede clasificar la
música según su función
la música sirve paralelo
hace varios años fui quiosquero me había
tomado por
costumbre siempre al principio de mes
cuando cobraba pasaba antes de tomarlo
en colectivo por una disquería y me
compraba un sí a ver si sabía cuál a
veces no lo encontraba y esta vez por
recomendación de un amigo me compré un
disco de cigarros
la compre
me tomé el 60 me bajé en mi casa a comer
un silloncito que había y unos
auriculares y le display
fue la primera vez que escuché un disco
de comienzo a final sin ninguna
interrupción
atrapó completamente yo como decía
recién escuchaba rock y esto era otra
cosa de sonidos muy chiquititos rozando
el silencio a texturas cargadas un pulso
bien marcado fue
y lo podía clasificar de ninguna manera
encontrar una etiqueta fue como
descubrió un color nuevo golpe
todavía el algo que no conocía
se puede clasificar la música según su
función
durante casi 10 años tuve participé en
una banda que se llamaba cara de nam y
una vez nos invitan a tocar a una fiesta
nacional al escenario principal
participamos tocando dos o tres temas y
el señor que estaba de locutor encargado
del escenario nos despide diciendo
muchas gracias a los chicos de caravana
y su música para reflexionar
vamos a cantar algo así
[Música]
o sea están presionando
[Aplausos]
sirve para algo la música
yo creo que sí
cuando la usamos
y relacionarse con la música de esa
manera tiene que ver lo que está
íntimamente conectada con el
entretenimiento con usarla ahora hay un
momento
en donde la música deja de ser un adorno
cuando le escuchamos cuando además de
darle play
nos acercamos a ella con atención le
damos el tiempo y el espacio necesario
para que nos cuente
es ahí donde creo que eso invisible que
es la música se vuelve un poquito
visible adentro nuestro
y de alguna manera
nos sentimos un poquito más a salvo
a
y
ah
[Música]
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]